Copenhagen the Danish capital is seen as
Scandinavia's most important fashion
city and the style Danish women favor is
quite representative of all of northern
Europe
Danish women have a clearly defined
style they certainly don't work in
finding clothes but see behind us this
woman writes Denmark's most popular
fashion blog anywho 27 year old
Stephanie kuntala the way she's dressed
is super cool high fashion the fat
sneakers the bare legs especially are
really important in the jeans with a bit
of print together with a simple t-shirt
the bag the hair worn more or less
undone undone so come on down and come
closer I like to match top and bottom I
like when it's you know the same print I
think it looks kind of cool very typical
my style because I always try to make it
kind of casual I think it is also kind
of typical Copenhagen style in a way
because a lot of girls like to wear
denim and loose t-shirts and they always
wear sneakers
yeah things are for PETA and right off
the bat you see a beautiful woman who
could be a model
typical Denmark with her bicycle and
shopping basket in the oversized peasant
blouse wonderful
I can only say really beautiful
everything is closed in Copenhagen
international labels from luxury to
avant-garde are clustered in the city
center Stephanie's favorite shop is a
concept store belonging to the Danish
brand would would rather boyish style is
also typical for women from the Nordic
countries they don't like to get dressed
up as vans right it's not very in there
miss kneesocks a lot a must this season
leopard prints in every variation they
like the jacket because of the the neon
colours on the sleeves and I think it's
really cool with the print feedback I
know how the unnatural fear in that the
skin puts you in mind of a trophy I
think that Nordic women in particular
still have very archaic they know they
need a strong man to bring a leopard
skin back home with the cave they
haven't shed this instinct animal prints
animal prints and still grieved make a
woman want to buy and show the others
that my man was brave yours is a wimp
stephanie has had her own shop for
almost two years
stocked almost exclusively with
Scandinavian brands she wants to only
offer designs that she personally likes
I think it's represent Scandinavian
design quite well because it's very
minimalistic and Danish designers works
with silhouettes and volume and they
like to make like suitable pieces that
match together
Stephanie lives just two blocks away she
travels often for her shop and her blog
so she's all the happier when she gets
to spend some time in the comfort of her
home I see a dog she's fishing I look at
this denim outfit with the matching
faded trousers it's a little bit of a
tease chic isn't it but girls who didn't
experience the eighties who grew up in
the 90s think it's a bit daring because
anything from the 80s is seen as
tasteless Marco is good the reach of
good days shows confidence staying
within the bounds of the good taste is
something for the mainstream this is
called a sous-vide burger in the evening
Stephanie is invited to a gallery
opening
vanished a superfan mm I think it's
super when they show off their legs and
wear a flowered print or something an
evening or a muster it's a little
bohemian hem just behind us it's even
called Bubba bohemian bourgeois this
bohemian bourgeois but it's certainly
not the bohemian living in poverty yeah
but they're living bourgeoisie or sois
it I don't think people in Copenhagen
dress up very much when they go out they
like to look like they don't care but
they do
Stephanie gondola is typical of women in
Copenhagen with their simple sporty yet
still feminine Flair